We now have a trapped
door for solving phi.
If you know the factorization
for N, then finding phi N
is easy.
For example, the prime
factorization of 77
is 7 times 11.
So phi of 77 is 6 times 10-- 60.
Step three, how to
connect the phi function
to modular exponentiation.
For this, he turned
to Euler's Theorem,
which is a relationship
between the phi
function and modular
exponentiation as follows.
m to the power of phi n
is congruent to 1 mod n.
This means you could pick
any two numbers, such
that they do not
share a common factor.
Let's call them m then n.
Say m equals 5 and n equals 8.
Now, when you raise m to
the power of phi n, or 4,
and divide by n, you will
always be left with 1.
Now we just need to
modify this equation using
two simple rules.
First, if you raise the
number 1 to any exponent k,
you always get 1.
In the same way, we can
multiply the exponents phi n
by any number k, and
the solution is still 1.
Second, if you multiply
1 by any number, say m,
it always equals m.
In the same way, we can
multiply the left side by m
to get m on the right-hand side.
And this can be simplified as
m to the power of k times phi
n plus 1.
This is the breakthrough.
We now have an
equation for finding
the e times d, which
depends on phi n.
Therefore, it's
easy to calculate
d only if the factorization
of n is known,
meaning d should be
Alice's private key.
It's the trap door
which will allow
her to undo the effect of e.
Let's do a simple example to
see all of this in action.
Say Bob has a
message he converted
into a number using
a padding scheme.
Let's call this m.
Then Alice generates her public
and private key as follows.
First, she generates two random
prime numbers of similar size
and multiplies them
to get n-- 3,127.
Then she calculates
phi of n easily,
since she knows
the factorization
of n, which turns out to 3,016.
Next, she picks some
small public exponent e
with the condition that it must
be an odd number that does not
share a factor with phi n.
This case, she picks e equals 3.
Finally, she finds the value
of her private exponent
d, which in this case is 2 times
phi of n, plus 1, divided by 3,
or 2,011.
Now, she hides everything
except the value of n
and e, because n and e
make up her public key.
Think of it as an open lock.
She sends this to Bob to
lock his message with.
Bob locks his message
by calculating m
to the power of e mod n.
Call this c, his
encrypted message,
which he sends it back to Alice.
Finally, Alice
decrypts his message
using her private key, d,
accessed through her trap door.
c to the power of d mod n
equals Bob's original message m.
Notice that Eve, or
anyone else with c, n,
and e can only find the
exponent d if they can calculate
phi n, which requires
that they know
the prime factorization of n.
If n is large enough,
Alice can be sure
that this will take
hundreds of years
even with the most powerful
network of computers.
This trick was
immediately classified
after its publication.
However, it was independently
rediscovered in 1977
by Ron Rivest, Adi Shamir,
and Len Adleman, which
is why it's now known
as RSA encryption.
RSA is the most widely
used public key algorithm
in the world and the most
copied software in history.
Every internet user
on Earth is using
RSA or some variant of it,
whether they realize it or not.
Its strength relies
on the hardness
of prime factorization, which
is a result of deep questions
about the distribution
of prime numbers
a question which has
remained unsolved
for thousands of years.